When it comes to having attractive,
captivating body language, there are
only four things that you need to know.
And if you do these four, you will
immediately enter into the top 1% of
communicators. Here's what they are.
First, reveal your vitals. We naturally
move to defend ourselves when we feel a
threat. The problem is that we can enter
a defensive posture even when we aren't
in physical danger. We're just
experiencing social discomfort. And in
those situations, we may cover our faces
with our hands or shrink into ourselves
to protect our throats, chests, inner
arms, and groin.
>> The thing that I was really fascinated
by and and always have been is um
people. First, let me say this. I care
deeply about the democratic process and
protecting its integrity.
>> This reflex is tough because not only
does it make us look awkward, it makes
us feel more afraid. The solution is to
reveal your vital spots. This means
uncrossing your arms, opening up your
chest, lifting your chin, and turning
your palms and arms outward facing. You
can take this even further and make
larger gestures that get your arms off
of your sides. Whoa. And this all will
have the immediate effect of making you
look and feel more confident. And if you
really want to take this all the way,
you can incorporate more platonic
touching with people that you're
speaking with. This might mean a hug
when most people would shake hands, high
fives during conversation, or shoulder
pats and hugs when people say stuff that
make you laugh.
>> God, mom, you're in frame. I promise
you're not cut out.
>> Okay.
>> Sometimes though, your body will do
things that you just can't control.
You'll get redfaced, sweat profusely, or
your hands will just feel like they
can't stop making jittery movements,
even if you're not aware of it.
revealing vitals won't be enough in
those cases and telling yourself to stop
sweating or shaking will just make
things worse. That is because those
behaviors are run by our autonomic
nervous system. So, what should you do
when you've lost control in this way?
Well, instead of just beating yourself
up and saying you need to stop, you want
to verbally own your experience. Share
that you're feeling excited or nervous
or don't know what to do with your
hands. When you do this in a self-loving
way, it will almost always get a laugh.
I'm so nervous.
>> Are you?
>> Oh my goodness.
>> What are you nervous about? What are you
nervous about?
>> Oh goodness. I think everything. You I'm
such a huge fan of you. I actually had a
crush on you when I was younger.
>> Truly. Truly.
>> When you verbally own your experience,
you are signaling to your body that you
hear its discomfort. You're not ignoring
it. You are just choosing to move
forward with the discomfort. And this
will stop the loop of silently beating
yourself up for feeling uncomfortable,
which is what was keeping you jittery,
sweaty, and redfaced in the first place.
And if you look here at how Jacob
settled in after what he said, you can
see how verbally owning his experience
helped him to naturally shift from those
jittery movements at the beginning to a
much more confident body language later
on. Now, the next point is extremely
subtle yet incredibly powerful, and it's
developing eye contact that is strong
where most people are weak. You see,
most people make fine eye contact when
they're listening, but when it comes
time to speak, they find it nearly
impossible to hold. So, they wind up
gathering their thoughts by looking away
from their conversation partner, which
can make the other person lose interest
in what they're saying.
>> Transcendence
um really is is about um
I I I think it's a very unique film.
>> Now, contrast that with someone like
Bill Clinton, who is the best I have
ever seen at this. Watch the percentage
of time that he maintains eye contact
while speaking with a woman in the town
hall. It is so effective that you can
see her nodding. And even his opponent,
George Bush, could sense that he was
getting crushed. In my state, when
people lose their jobs, there's a good
chance I'll know him by their names.
People that have lost their jobs, lost
their livelihood, lost their health
insurance.
>> Through the entirety of that answer,
Clinton made eye contact 92% of the
time. What I see in most people is that
they make eye contact with their
listener less than half of the time. So,
your goal should be to just hold eye
contact a bit longer than is immediately
comfortable when you are talking. Over
time, you'll learn how to gather your
thoughts while maintaining eye contact,
and that will help you develop an
incredibly captivating gaze. But I
should say, this is where we run into an
issue at the core of all body language
training. Because on the one hand, we
want to stretch our comfort zones.
That's necessary to growing. We need to
try revealing our vitals and sustaining
eye contact through discomfort. But on
the other hand, it's exactly the
discomfort that makes you shut down and
have weak body language in the first
place. So, it can feel like you're being
pulled in two directions and then you
just might want to quit, stop working on
this stuff at all. And that is why it is
critical to keep in mind this final
point. Every single tool that you will
ever apply from this channel works
better when you treat it not as a chore,
but as an opportunity to explore what
feels good for you. So, when you're in
doubt, just ask what would feel good
right now. Matthew McConna is the
epitome of this. He slouches, rolls his
fingers, even kicks his feet up. But
>> how do we are we giving ourselves too
much credit?
>> Congratulations. You're the first guy to
put bare feet on this desk.
>> Oh, yeah.
>> Just want to congratulate you. Thank
you.
>> And all of this makes him come across as
extremely confident, even when he's not
following the quote unquote rules
perfectly. Watch how even despite his
lacking eye contact, he can still hold
attention when he tells a story.
>> Look, there's a lot of fivestar players
who don't have the hustle and and then
there's a lot of
>> some of the most talented ones, right?
Because it comes too easy to them.
>> Yeah.
>> The reason this works is because when
you prioritize feeling good, you will
start to exume your own positive
self-image. And that in turn makes
others respect your self-worth and it
invites them to feel good in your
presence. So yes, stretch yourself some
to apply these tips, but do it in
service of your own enjoyment rather
than from a place of beating yourself
up. A great concrete way to do that is
to only spend 5 minutes each day
consciously stretching your social
comfort zone. From then just relax into
whatever interactions you're having.
that'll make you develop magnetism
extremely quickly and the process
becomes much more fun. Now, if you want
to go even faster and enhance the speed
of this, you can follow our daily action
guides to get concrete steps to max out
your charisma. People have done our
30-day program have gotten promotions.
They've started dating new partners and
develop closer relationships with their
family and their friends. And if that
all sounds like something that you'd be
interested in, you can click the link on
screen to check out Charisma University.